THOSE OF THE COMMITTEE STARTED
AND WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
A QUORUM YET SO LET'S CALL-
CALL OR THE HEARING IN THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. I'LL BEGIN
BY SHARING A FEW NOTES ABOUT
THE LEAD LOGISTICS OF OUR
HEARING TODAY THESE STEPS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN TO HELP PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO ENSURE
MEMBERS. OF THE MEDIA PUBLIC
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDS
TODAY. WE ARE ENSURING THERE
ARE MULTIPLE WAYS TO OBSERVE
AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING. TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON VIA THE
PHONE OR VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. EVERYONE IN THE
CAPITAL MUST WEAR A MASK THIS
INCLUDES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY. STATION AT THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. LIKEWISE EVERYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM O THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATIONS AS
REQUIRED TO PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AS BEAR WITH US IF
WE NEED TO WORK THROUGH ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PRESENT
IN THE HEARING ROOM WE ARE
REQUIRING PHYSICAL DISINFLATION
ALL THE DIRECTIONS OF OUR
SERGEANTS AND POSTED GUIDANCE
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION WITNESSES IF A WITNESS
PER FIRST REVISED TESTIMONY VIA
VIDEO CONFERENCE- IS UNABLE TO
ENTER THE CAPITAL DUE TO THE
CAPACITY LIMIT A WITNESS MAY
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED AT
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
FOR OUR PHONE WITNESSES WE WILL
AGAIN BE USING- MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYONE
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN ZERO
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO TWO AND THE
PIN IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. SEVEN ZERO
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO TWO AND THE
PEN IS TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AND- YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE SIMPLY
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN PLEASE CALL ONE
AUTHORED THE BILL. YOU PLAN TO
TESTIFY IS ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU THE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE. ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE DOWN ISSUES
EVER HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2096 AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP TRY
TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMPANY'S
WEBSITE. FOR EACH BILL WE ARE
FOLLOWING UP. ALLOWING UP TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT INTO MAIN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THESE
WITNESSES HAVE BEEN MADE KNOWN
TO THE COMMITTEE IN ADVANCE OF
THE HEARING. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CALL ASK A QUESTION OR PROVIDE
COMMENT FEATURES YOUR HAND AND
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE WHEN
IT'S- YOUR- TURN TO SPEAK. IF
YOUR PRESENT A BILL THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PRESENT THE
MICRO FREEZE PRESENT FROM THE
MICROPHONE AT THE WITNESS
TABLE. AGENDA UPDATES S. B.
FIVE TWENTY WILK HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA.
WITH THAT LET'S CALL THE ROLL
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM QUITE
YET WE DON'T STOP OKAY DO WE
HAVE ONE. OKAY RIGHT OR WRONG
EDUARDO GARCIA. MEGHAN DOLLY
HERE BENNETT. BIGELOW FRIEDMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA. KALRA LEVINE.
MURATSUCHI NO WHEN. RUBIO SALAS.
SMITH VIPTELA WARD. OKAY WE
HAVE A COURT. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THE SICK OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS CONSENT CALENDAR
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING BILLS SB
SEVEN AWAIT MELINDA'S AND S. B.
EIGHT TWO ONE THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE. MOVED BY MR BIGELOW
SECOND MY- MISTER SMITH. YEAH
OKAY. EDUARDO GARCIA DOLLY HI
DALY AYE BENNETT. BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN. CRISTINA
GARCIA IT'S CRISTINA GARCIA I
KALRA. LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI. WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS. SALAS I SMITH SMITH
I'D BE A PRODUCER VIA DUBAI
WARD. YOU WANT TO GET. KALRA I.
OKAY JUST A CLARIFYING NOTE THE
NUMBER TO CALL IN I'M GONNA
REPEAT THIS TWICE IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE PEN IS.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. ONE WERE-
HOUSEKEEPING IS BEFORE YOU GET
OUR OUR BILL PRESENTATIONS I A
BIG KNOWLEDGE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS IN COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS WILSHIRE ALL VOICES
ARE HEARD HOWEVER CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK FOR REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON AND TALKING OR MAKING
LOUD NOISES WITH THE AUDIENCE
VETERANS SOUND LOUD THREATENING
OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE OR JUST ANY
DISCUSSIONS OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT THE BILL
HEARING IF AN INDIVIDUAL
DISRUPT OUR HEARING PROCESS I
WILL DIRECT THEM TO STOP WARN
THEM THAT CONTAINED
INSTRUCTIONS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT I MAY EVEN
TEMPORARY RECESSED THE HEARING.
AT THE CONDUCT CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS IN
ESCORTING INDIVIDUAL FROM THE
CAPITAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO BILL PRESENTATIONS. DOCTOR
PAN IS HERE. AND DOCTOR CAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH
AB SB THREE SIX NINE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A STIR
DOLLY AND MEMBERS- SACRAMENTO
REGION IN MANY COMMUNITIES THAT
RESIDE ALONG NOTE. CALIFORNIA
WATERWAYS OR SEVERE RISK OF
MAJOR FLOODING. A FACTOR MANY
SECTIONS OF THE LEVEE ALONG
SACRAMENTO RIVER THAT LACK A
HUNDRED YEAR AND THREE HUNDRED
YEAR FLOOD PROTECTIONS. THAT'S
THE MOST COMMON DISASTER RISK
OF FLOODING HAS BEEN HAS
PROMPTED MANY TO BUY FLOOD
INSURANCE EVEN FOR SOME CITIES
TO ENACT BUILDING MORATORIUMS.
IN ORDER TECH LIFE AND PROPERTY
FUTURE FLOOD CONTROL MEASURES
MUST INCLUDE COORDINATED
COOPERATION BY LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO ENSURE
PROPER PLANNING AND STAKEHOLDER
COLLABORATION. SO SB THREE
SIXTY NINE ESTABLISHES THE
YELLOW BYPASS CAGE. CASH SLOW
PARTNERSHIP MULTI BENEFIT
PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM CODIFIES
AND EVO YOU SIGNED BY FIFTEEN
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES ARE AUTHORIZED THE
PREPARATION. OF A MASTER PLAN
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECTS. TODAY I HAVE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. RICK
JOHNSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SECOND AREA FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY AND JACK WELCOME. TO
SPEAK TO. SPEAK MORE ON THE
BILL AND ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PER NIGHT BUT THANK YOU. HE YOU
LET'S MOVE TO THE- WITNESS ON
THE PHONES. MORNING MY NAME'S
RICK JOHNSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE FACTORY FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE SIXTY
NINE. SOFTBANK'S THE CENTER PAN
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL POOREST.
YOUR BIKE PATHS WITH ORIGINALLY
CONSTRUCTED ABOUT A CENTURY AGO
A PART OF A SINGLE PURPOSE
FLOOD CONTROL SYSTEM WE HAVE
PROTECTED THE STATE CAPITOL IN
MAJOR URBAN AREAS FROM FLOODING.
PARKER RECOGNIZED THAT THE- OF
I PATH HAS EVOLVED INTO A
MULTIPURPOSE FACILITY. THAT
PROVIDES CRITICAL HABITAT FOR
ENDANGERED SPECIES IT'S
AGRICULTURAL IF THE SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENT. OF THE LOCAL RESULT
KANEMI AND IT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF WATER SUPPLY AND
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT RECREATION.
IT IS NOW TIME TO UPGRADE THE
YELLOW BY PASSED HOWEVER. THIS
TIME WE NEED TO FROM A- PLANS
WE NEED TO CREATE A MASTER PLAN
THAT NOT ONLY ADDRESSES
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BY PASS TO
HANDLE THE LARGER BLOOD FLOWS
THAT WE KNOW ARE COMING DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT ALSO ALLOWS
FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO HABITAT
AGRICULTURE WATER SUPPLY IN
RECREATION AND ADDRESSES OTHER
LOCAL AND REGIONAL MEETING. IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY CONGRESS
DIRECTED THE US ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO PERFORM A TOPIC TO
STUDY THE- A BY PASS WITH SMALL
PARTICLES IT'S PERSPECTIVE.
CONGRESS SPECIFICALLY
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR BIKE PATH
IN CASH IN PARTNERSHIP AND THE
DIRECTED THE COR TO WORK WITH
THIS PARTNERSHIP FIFTY THREE
SIXTY NINE IT'S IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THE PARTNERSHIP AT
THE STATE LEVEL. AND WE BELIEVE
IT WILL RESULT IN PARTICIPATING
AGENCIES FUNCTIONING IN A MORE
FORMAL FACTION. FURTHER SB
THREE SIXTY NINE WILL
DEMONSTRATE THE STATE SUPPORT
FOR MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
CORPORATE THE STUDY MANDATED BY
CONGRESS YES HOLLISTER THIRTEEN
COMPETING FOR FEDERAL FUNDS
REQUIRED TO PERFORM THE STUDY.
SB THREE THIRTY NINE HAS BROAD
SUPPORT AND WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. THIS PACKAGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE YOU WE CAN
MOVE OUR NEXT.
MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE OUR NEXT WITNESS ON THE
LINE. I DO NOT SHOW CHECK LOCAL
ON THE CALL AT THIS TIME I
INVITE THEM IF THEY ARE ON IS
AN ATTENDEE IN ERROR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AND WE CAN
GET YOU PROP IT UP. DOES NOT
APPEAR THERE IN THE TURN IN
TENANTS CURRENTLY. OKAY I DO
NOT SEE ANY- REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. FOR SB
THREE SIX NINE- ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY IN PERSON. LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. FOR S. B. GREAT
WILL. THANK YOU THIRD PLACE
YOURSELF IN A QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE WILL SPEAK IN WITH MY
NUMBER SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KAREN LYING ON THE
OTHER SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THIS
MORNING AND THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN AFTER AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU WILL NOW GO TO ONE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO THAT'S- TWO YOUR
LINE IS A- THANK YOU MA'AM CARE
THIS IS A- BUT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY SOCCER. AND SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY AT. THANK YOU
ON A GROWING NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
THAT'S THREE FIVE ZERO ONE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING AUDREY
RETIRED CHECK FROM
CHRISTIANITY'S ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND PLEASE ALLOW A
MOMENT WE HAVEN'T HAD ONE
PERSON THAT IS JUST QUEUED UP.
AND WILL THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO TO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBERS REALLY
A HOLIDAY EDUCATION CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN PART THANK
YOU. AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. RIGHT THANK YOU. ANY
EMOTION. THANK YOU MR
MURATSUCHI AND MR LEVINE. CALL
THE ROLL. SUPER CLOSE- DO YOU
WANNA CLOSE I'M SORRY DOCTOR
CAN- THEIR STRUGGLE YES WHEN I
PUT TWENTY MAKING. MEGHAN DOLLY
HI MEGHAN DOLLY I BENNETT.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA. KALRA KALRA I.
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN AND
WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS AYE AYES SMITH. SMITH I
HAVE TO DO IT VEHICULAR I WARD.
THE BILL BILLS OUT THANK YOU DR
PAN. THIS MISTER HERTZBERG HERE.
NO OR HUESO. DO WE NEED TO TAKE
A MORE VOTES ON THE CONCERT.
SORRY TO LEAVE THANKS FOR THE
CONSENSUS EVERYBODY HERE EXCEPT
FOR. SOME REAL ISSUE
DISPLACEMENT. SO WHAT DO YOU
WHAT DO I DO IF THERE'S NO.
YEAH. HELLO SENATOR HUESO THANK
YOU. THE RATE SHOULD BE IN ON
SB. SIX TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE I RISE TO PRESENT SB SIX
TWENTY FOR A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH AND PROMOTE.
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY IN OUTDOOR
ACCESS AS A GOAL FOR ALL STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THAT
MANAGE NATURAL REEF RESOURCES.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE WILL
GLADLY ACCEPT AMENDMENTS ARE
PROPOSED. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG. AND A WONDERFUL TRADITION
OF TRYING TO PROVOKE ACCESS- IN
OUR PARKS AND OUR COASTLINE.
AND HELPING TO CREATE PROGRAMS
THAT WILL- IMPROVE ACCESS
HOWEVER DURING THE PANDEMIC. OF
A. WE SAW THAT LOTS AND LOTS OF
WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE THE
IMPACTS OF COVERT NINETEEN ON
THE STAND AT HOME ORDER REALLY
MAGNIFIED THE OBSTACLES OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
FACED IN ACCESSING. HOW DOOR
SPACES AND RECREATION CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
FOR STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
BY ADDRESSING THESE BARRIERS
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST TO CERTAIN
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY LACKED THEM FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE BARRIERS TO
ACCESS. SB SIX TWENTY FOUR
WOULD ADD A NEW DIVISION TO THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE TO
ADDRESS THIS. WE HAVE JOSE
GONZALEZ REPRESENTING THE
LATINO OUTDOORS IN PARKS NOW
COALITION THAT I BELIEVE IS ON
THE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO OF.
EXPAND ON MY COMMENTS BUT- I
HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TO THIS BILL HAS NOT
RECEIVED- ANY OPPOSITION AND- I
ALSO BELIEVE THIS BILL HASN'T
RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES FOR THE
PROCESS AS WELL SO IT LOOKS TO
HAVE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT. ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THE
MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK YOU
MISTER WAY SO. LET'S OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO JOSE HERE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GREAT
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS- GAS YES
THEY DO APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TWO FOUR- MY NAME IS
JOSE GONZALEZ AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR IMAGES
SELECTING ALL DOORS AND A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE PARKS
NOW COALITION BOTH OF WHICH ARE
EMBEDDED WITH VALUES OF THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY. TO STARTED HAS
BEEN NOTED IT'S THE PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS THE
TIME SPENT OUTDOORS ARE
UNDENIABLE WHICH WAS ALSO
CLEARLY NOTED AN AMPLIFIED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT MAKE BUT THESE
BENEFITS AND OUTDOOR SPACES AND
RECREATION ARE NOT EQUALLY
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE
SOMETHING WHICH WAS ALSO-
UNFORTUNATELY AMPLIFIED. NO
RETURN BUT DEMOCRATS. HOW TO
STAND PAUL ISN'T. SUCH AS THE
STATE- WHY PARKS PROGRAM IN THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM.
BOTH OF WHICH WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT THEY EXIST- THE STATE HAD
MADE PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE BARRIERS THAT HAS
MADE THE OUTDOORS INACCESSIBLE
FOR SOME PEOPLE. EQUITABLE
ACCESS IS MORE ABOUT THAN JUST
PHYSICAL ACCESS IN ACHIEVING IT
WILL REQUIRE ATTENTION TO
REDUCING OTHER SOCIAL CULTURAL
AND INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS FOR
THOSE THAT FACE THEM.
ADDITIONALLY EQUITABLE ACCESS
CANNOT BE A CALL WE ADVANCE
ONLY IN CERTAIN CONTEXTS UNDER
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS BUT SOMETHING
WE NEED TO PROMOTE IN EVERY
INSTANCE POSSIBLE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE ACHIEVING SOME TAX
WHAT I CONSIDER SOME TACTICAL
SUCCESSES TO CURRENT PROGRAMS
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO SO
WITHIN A MORE ENCOMPASSING
STRATEGIC. VISION FRAMEWORK. SB
SIX TWENTY FOUR WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT THIS IS THE CASE BY
STATUS IN THAT IT IS THE POLICY
OF THE STATE TO ENSURE ALL
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
STATE'S NATURAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES. PAYING SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO THOSE THAT
HISTORICALLY FACED
DISPROPORTIONATE BARRIERS AND
EXCLUSION. THE BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY IN THE
ENTITIES HOUSE WITHIN IT I TO
TAKE DELIBERATE ACTION TO
IDENTIFY AND REMOVE BARRIERS TO
EQUITABLE ACCESS PRIORITISING
THOSE ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THE OUTDOORS. IN
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE AND ALL
CAN ENJOY THE OUTDOORS AND IT'S
BROAD IN SCOPE AND INCLUDES
SCOUT. AND THE BENEFITS THAT IT
PROVIDES SOMETHING THAT I
CONSIDER TO BE QUINTESSENTIALLY
CALIFORNIA. SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR HOW WEST OF FORTY
THREE TO SHIP ON THE STILL. AND
WE RESPECT RESPECTFULLY URGE
AND I INFO ON THIS. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN. THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. OR AT THE
REMOTE VIEWING STATIONS. THIS
ROTARY- CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT. YES
IF YOU WISH TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THAT'S THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ONE OF
THEM YOU DON'T KNOW WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU. A GROWING
NUMBER THIRTY ONE THAT'S THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SHARON NUMBERS IS JAMIE
GO ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING A STORE
CALIFORNIA RELIEF ARMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA TROUT
AND TROUT UNLIMITED ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NORTH
AMERICA CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONSERVATION VOTERS. FOR BY
NUMBER THIRTY SIX FIVE SIX
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THEY'VE BEEN
PROVIDED THEIR LINE NUMBER BUT
AS A VERY ONLY ONE STILL IN Q.
I WILL OPEN THEIR LINE AND
HOPEFULLY THEIR VOICES MAY BE
HEARD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES. THE MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
THIS IS MEANT FOR YOU ON BEHALF
OF PREVENTION INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX TWO FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU THERE'S NO REGISTERED-
OPPOSITION FOR WITNESSES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SB SIX TO FOUR OR
THE REMOTE VIEWING STATION. MR
MURRAY WE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO. SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILLIONAIRE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF THANK YOU AND
HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP PROPOSITION AT THIS
TIME MEDICARE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU. MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU- AND JUST BRIEFLY ONE OF
THANK THE CENTER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I'D ALSO
CALLED UPON THE IN ADDITION
LAST YEAR AB THIRTY THIRTY
WHICH BUBBLE LED TO A DOCTOR'S
DOCTOR ORDERED YEAR AND IS BE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH WOULD HAVE
GONE EVEN A STEP FURTHER AND-
ACTUALLY A DEEMED THE ACCESS TO
NATURE HUMAN RIGHTS- THAT BEING
SAID THE BILL'S BEEN STALLED-
BUT IN ANY CASE THE GOAL I
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THIS I
THINK IT'S ALIGNED- WITH WHAT-
WHAT WHAT THE- WHY NOT AND THE
SPONSORS TRYING TO. ACHIEVE
WITH THE SB THIRTY I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AT SOME POINT WE CAN GET
TO THAT POINT AND THIS WOULD BE
CLEARLY AS A SIGNIFICANT.
BUILDING BLOCK TOWARDS THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER MEMBER. RIGHT THANK YOU.
MISTER HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK MANAGER
MEMBERS AS A LEADER ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES CALIFORNIA
IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO COLOR
CODE OF FIVE. THAT IT IS THE
POLICY OF THE STATE TO ENSURE
EQUITY AND ACCESS AND
AUTHORIZED AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TAKE TARGETED
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS BARRIERS
THERE IS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION
AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION S TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
EDUARDO GARCIA. MEGAN DOLLY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS I SENATE.
BENNETT I BIGELOW. FRIEDMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
KNOW WHEN. NEW AND NOT VOTING
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH. BE A PRODUCER VIA
PADILLA I WARD WARD I. NEWMAN
FROM NOT VOTING TÁI. THANK
YOU THAT FLOWS OUT THE MYSTERY
SO. WE HAVE ONE MORE BEAR ONE
MORE BILL SB FIVE I TO MINISTER
HERTZBERG AND HE'S. NOT.
MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS ON BILLS
PLEASE. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA
BENNETT. FRIEDMAN MURATSUCHI.
FOR CASE THAT. MERCI GI. DID
YOU MISTER MISTER BENNETT DID
YOU GET HIM I GUESS OKAY-
BENNETT I THANK. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BENNETT. BEN AND I.
YOU WERE ALREADY ON IT. I
THINK. IT'S SB THREE SIX NINE
ABSENT MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
BENNETT. BENNETT I FRIEDMAN.
HAVE THE ABILITY. WARD I.
MISTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU I'M
READY FOR S. B. FIVE FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT WAS
GOOD TO STAND HERE. GOOD OLD
DAYS. I WANT TO- INITIALLY-
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND TO THINK PABLO YOUR STAFF
SHARE FOR A WORKING WITH US ON
THIS MEASURES WAS A LAST MINUTE
REFERRAL TO DOUBLE REFERRAL SO
THE TIMELINE FOR THE AMENDMENTS
AND THE MECHANICS OF GETTING
THINGS DONE WERE A LITTLE
TIGHT. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. ON BRIEFLY EVERYBODY
KNOWS. IN THE HEADLINES OF THE
NEWSPAPERS WE ARE FACING AN
EXTRAORDINARY DROPPED. WE HAVE
WORK TO I WORK WITH THE MEASURE
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN SERIES
OF. EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE ON WATER CONSERVATION.
AND THERE WAS A HOLE IN THAT
PROCESS FOR SMALL WATER
DISTRICTS DISTRICTS THAT SERVE
BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE. **** UPS. IN THIS
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
THAT ARE SUFFERING
EXTRAORDINARILY NOT BECAUSE OF
THE DROUGHT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TRUCKED IN WATER IT'S REALLY A
HORRIBLE SITUATION. SO WE MADE
A RECOMMENDATION ONE OF THE
REPORTS IT WAS PART OF THIS
EFFORT. TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
STRATEGIES TO DEAL WITH THE
SMALLER DISTRICTS AND THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN IN THE GOVERNORS
OFFICE SO. WE PUT THIS. BILL
TOGETHER TO BASICALLY REQUIRE.
THESE DISTRICTS THESE- SMALLER
DISTRICTS TO PREPARE FOR THE
DROUGHT TO DEAL WITH DRIED
WELLS TO DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE NOT VERY BIG PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA BUT THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY PROBLEMS FOR
CALIFORNIANS INCO SMALLER
COMMUNITIES IN THE IMPACTS THAT
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE ON THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR LIVELIHOODS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND SO I WE'VE
GOT A COUPLE WITNESSES AND I DO
WANT TO- ADDRESS JUST FOR A
MOMENT IF I COULD. ARM THE
OPPOSITION BY THE- COUNTIES.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS FOR
A LONG TIME. I CHAIRED THE
GOVERNANCE FINANCE COMMITTEE IN
THE OTHER HOUSE. AND I WROTE
FOR FOUR YEARS THE LAST CALL
ACT KNOCKS CORTESE HERTZBERG
ACT IT'S BEEN A HUGE AMOUNT OF
TIME WORKING WITH COUNTIES.
COUNTY NOW TELLS US THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
WHICH IS JUST NOT ACCURATE IN
THE LETTER AND IT IS- QUITE
AMAZING TO ME- WE REACHED OUT
TO THEM ON FEBRUARY TENTH TWO
INTRODUCED THE BILL. AND WE HAD
THESE LATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND OUR STAFF
WAS INVOLVED WITH THEM EVERY
SINGLE STEP OF THE WAY. I DON'T
MIND IF SOMEONE OPPOSES A
MEASURE IT HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. OUR FAMILIES OPPOSE
THINGS WE WANT TO DO THAT'S
PART OF OUR BUSINESS AS WE TALK
ABOUT. VARIOUS ISSUES OF PUBLIC
POLICY BUT WHAT I DO MIND. IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT GROUPS.
LIKE THE COUNTIES WHO I HOLD IN
HIGH REGARD FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MY MEMORY. BEING IN THIS
BUSINESS FOR DECADES. TELLS US
THAT WE CAN COMMUNICATE WITH
THEM AND THAT'S JUST NOT
ACCURATE. PART OF IT WAS THE
TIMING AT THE LAST MINUTE. BUT
EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN THE LOOP. IN THIS
STUFF. AND I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW IS. A MEMBER OF. THE OTHER
HOUSES FORMER LEADER OF THIS
HOUSE I HOLD THIS PROCESS IN
HIGH REGARD IT WOULD NEVER. DO
ANYTHING. AS A PROFESSIONAL IN
THIS BUSINESS. THAT EVER SIDE
SWIPED ANYBODY I MIGHT HIT HIM
IN THE NOSE ON AN ISSUE THAT I
DIDN'T LIKE A MONTH. SOME
PEOPLE KNOW THAT. BUT I WOULD
NEVER SITES WIPE THEM SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR THIS
WAS A LAST MINUTE OPPOSITION BY
THE WAY. THE OPPOSITION LETTER
FROM THE COUNTY DID NOT EVEN
COME TO MY OFFICE WE ONLY SAW.
THAT WAS PUT ON THE ELECTRONIC
NOTIFICATION THAT THERE WAS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT. STAFF OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT
WORKING WITH US THE LAST MINUTE
BECAUSE LAST NIGHT REFERRALS.
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY- ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND- I BELIEVE WE HAVE
WITNESSES AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE BECAUSE I'M NOT
READING ANY PAPERS. SO WHOEVER
THEY ARE. PLEASE A GET ON THE
TELEPHONE. THANK YOU THE FIRST
WITNESS I HAVE IS I'M JONATHAN
NELSON FROM A COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER. ON THE PHONE. YES THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN NELSON AND I'M THAT
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ENSURE ACTIONS TO TAKE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY.
LIVING IN SMALL AND WILL
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE HERE IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE Q. WHICH WILL HELP.
CALIFORNIA BE MORE PREPARED FOR
DROUGHT WATER SHORTAGE
EMERGENCY BY IMPLEMENTING BASIC
PRACTICE DROUGHT PLANNING AND
COORDINATION MEASURES- AND FROM
THE OUTSET WE DO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION THAT
CAN OCCUR HERTZBERG AND HIS-
REALLY GREAT TEAM FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. SO
JUST QUICKLY WE AND OUR
PARTNERS WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE LAST DROUGHT YOU
WORK DIRECTLY WITH COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE DEVASTATED AND THE
LACK ROUTE ONE COMMUNITY IT WAS
EACH PORTED OVER THOUSAND BLOCK
WATER AT ONE TIME. AND THAT WAS
JUST ONE COMMUNITY AND IT WAS
PAINFUL- AS YOU CAN IMAGINE AND
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF BASIC
PRACTICE PLANNING AND
COORDINATION THE DATE WAS LAST
GRAMBLING TO KEEP UP WITH THAT
DROUGHT EMERGENCY FAMILIES ARE
ONCE AGAIN RIGHT NOW LOSING
ACCESS TO WATER WE AND OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PARTNERS.
ARE GETTING CALLS NEARLY EVERY
DAY FROM FAMILIES THAT ARE
BLOCKED OR ARE STRUGGLING WITH
ACCESS TO WATER AND IT'S NOT
EVEN SUMMER. AND. IT'S ONLY THE
SECOND YEAR THAT DROUGHT. THE
OF THE FIVE BY TWO- ARMADA- IN
OUR INFORMED PAPER- ALSO. AT
THE- THESE BASS THAT INCLUDE.
MAKING SURE OUR SMALL WATER
COULD HAVE EMERGENCY DRAW PLAN
IN PLACE. TO SURE THAT THE
STATE MAINTAINS THAT THE ENDING
INTER AGENCY TASK FORCE. ON
DROUGHT AND MAKING SURE THAT
COUNTY THAT CHECK BOX TO
WELCOME IT FORMS THAT WE CAN
ASK WHETHER THE REASON FOR NEW
WELL IT'S DUE TO EXPIRE FAILING
WELL. BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT WITH
ANY PROVISION. AND WE VRY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL WE
ALL SHARE THE SAME GOAL WHICH
IS TO CLOSE. ALL THE STEPS IN
THE BILL ARE VERY MODERATE BUT
WHEN TAKEN TOGETHER THEY WILL
MATTER FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT
GOT HAMMERED BY THE LAST
DROUGHT AND THAT ARE HURTING.
ALREADY IN THIS DROUGHT WE'RE
IN A DROUGHT EMERGENCY WE ARGUE.
SUPPORT CRAPPIE BITE BY TWO.
THANK YOU A THE NEXT. PLEASE.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING IT'S NOT UPDATED YET MY
NAME IS DANIELLE BOB HYDE
CALIFORNIA BUT UTILITIES AT THE
BEACH AND- WE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES AND PUBLICLY ON
ELECTRIC UTILITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE TWO- AS
JONATHAN ABOUT THE NOTED
DROUGHT EACH YEAR IT'S BECOMING
MORE SEVERE BY THE DAY WELL
LARGER WATER SYSTEMS HAVE
ROBUST WATER SHORTAGE
CONTINGENCY PLANS THAT HELP
THEM AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
PREPARE FOR AN INJURED DRY
TIMES LIKE THIS ONE. GIVEN THE
CLASSROOM THREE THOUSAND
CONNECTIONS IN COMMUNITIES RELY
ON DOMESTIC WELL YOU NOT HAVE
THE PLAN FOR TIMES OF DROUGHT
MAKING CONSERVATION A WAY OF
LIFE LEGISLATION J. BEING
CHAMPIONED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND SENATOR HERTZBERG
WHICH INCLUDED REQUIREMENTS TO
BRIDGE THIS GAP SAID PROVISIONS
RESULTED IN THE CREATION OF THE
STATE COUNTY DRIVE BY THREE
GROUP OF WHICH MEAN YOU AIN'T
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER WHERE
MEMBERS. SB FIVE FIVE Q. AND
OUTGROWTH OF THE FEEDBACK
REPORT AND INCLUDES REASONABLE
AND CRITICAL PLANNING TOOL THEY
WILL THIRTY SYSTEMS IN
COMMUNITIES DOWN PATH OF WATER
SHORTAGE AND DROUGHT RESILIENCY
AND NOTIFY THE SENATOR MR NOW
PLANNED WE UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONCERNS FROM COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE AND WE ARE
COMMITTED YOUR TO OPEN DIALOGUE
TO LEARN MORE IN TRYING TO
FIND. OUT WHAT WORKS IT MUST BE
A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
BECAUSE TIME AND TIME AGAIN OUR
STATE EXPERIENCE DROUGHT CAN
HAPPEN FAMILIES CONTINUE TO
SUFFER OUR CURRENT SITUATION
HIGHLIGHTS THE URGENT NEED FOR
SB FIVE THANK YOU AND WILL
ALLOW THE MOCK MUNITY BE BETTER
PREPARED FOR WHEN THE NEXT
ROUND HEADS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK
YOU. ZERO ONE AND- IN THE ROOM
IN SOME. AT THE REMOTE. VIEWING
STATIONS. THIS MODERATOR CAN
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT AS SB. FIVE FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN A
GENERAL YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
WILL MOVE TO TESTIMONY OF
OPPOSITION AND THE FIRST-
WITNESS WE HAVE AS CATHERINE
FREEMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS CAPTAIN FRIEDMAN AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. GENERAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THE TO GATHER BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. I'M HERE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO IT
THAT'S THE FIVE FIVE TWO AS
AMENDED AND THAT'S OUTLINED IN
THE LETTER WE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS WEEK SPECIFIC TO
FOR THAT COUNTY REQUIREMENTS. I
THINK THAT'S MY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND BUY THE OTHER OUT-
TESTIMONY SB FIVE OF TWO WAS
INTENDED TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE COUNTY
CHILD ADVISORY GROUP WHICH
INCLUDED REPRESENTATIVES OF
BOTH OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS. THE
REPORT MAKES SEVENTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM HER
DROUGHT RESILIENCY AND OF ALL
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR ROLE
COMMUNITY BUT MA'AM THE
EMPHASIZES IT WILL TAKE TIME
EFFORT AND FUNDING TO CARRY OUT
ALL OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AMENDMENTS OUT OF SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL FINANCIALLY ONE A
LONG WAY TO MAKE THE BILL MORE
FEASIBLE BY ALLOWING- COUNTY
SENTIMENT AND I'LL TURN OF
PROCESS TO THE VERY THE VERY
SPECIFIC TROUT- TASK FORCE.
MANAGER ACUTELY AWARE OF
DROUGHT AND WATER ISSUES AND
MANY OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES ARE
EITHER BUDGET THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY OR HAVE A
SEAT ON THE LOCAL GSA. HOWEVER
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS SHARED
WITH OUR ORGANIZATION ON MONDAY
OF THIS WEEK GIVE US PAUSE AND
CONCERN WE HAVE HAD EXCELLENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
EARLY IN THE PROCESS AND
WELCOME THESE CONVERSATIONS. WE
DID REACH OUT TO THE SPONSORS
WHEN WE RECEIVE IT AND THEN
THAT. WE APPRECIATE THE TIGHT
TIMELINE DUE TO THE BILL
REFERRALS THAT WE HAVE NOT HAD
TIME TO THOROUGHLY ABOUT THE
AND THEN THAT'S WITH OUR
MEMBERS AND WE WELCOME THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION WITH OUR
SPONSORS AND THE BILL PARKER AT
THE HAVE IN THE PAST. LOOK AT
THE SPECIFIC A CHECKBOX
CHECKBOX THAT SIMPLY REPORTS
WHETHER A DRY WELL IT'S CAUSED
BY DROUGHT A WATER SHORTAGE.
VERIFY THAT THE COUNTY THE
RESIDENT HOW SHOULD WE
DETERMINE IF THE WELL IS TO TRY
TO DROUGHT OVER PUMPING BY
NEIGHBORS OR IN THE CASE OF
FOOTHILLS SHIFTING GEOLOGY.
FRACTURED ROCK AREAS. ONE IT
CHANGE OR NEW HYDRO DUE TO SHIP.
ABOUT AN- DIVERSE ON PRIVATE
PUBLIC. ILLEGAL BOX. THAT
SPECTRUM OF OUR TOWN. BUT LOOK
AT THAT HYDRO IN THAT OF THE-
YEAR. MORE FRIENDLY COULD BE A
MESS WITH THE WHILE ITSELF SO
TO TURN BECAUSE- IT'S- VERY.
LOCALLY CONTENT AND FRANKLY I'M
SOME CASES. I COUNTY WOULD NEED
TO HIRE SEVERITY. FIVE YEARS
ONE. PERCENT CERTAIN OF.
BECAUSE THEY- AND THEN THERE'S
THE INPUT. SO LET'S SAY RECEIVE
A FORM. WITH APARTMENT CHECK A-
BY DROUGHT. AND NOW FOR THE
THAT THE- IS REPORTER ON A
COUPLE AT. WEBSITE HOW DOES NOT.
MENTION AS THE PROPERTY. AND
SHARE IMAGES. WITH NO CONTACT
OTHER THAN THE ACTIONS THAT
THEIR MAIN BE A CO ON A- THOSE
THE QUESTIONS WERE ASKED OUR
MEMBERS NOW AND THOSE ARE
QUESTIONS WOULD LIKE TO.
DISCUSS WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
SO IF THE LISTENERS OUT THERE
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES RECENTLY ROLLED OUT
OF THE OFFICE SUPPORTING MY DRY
WATER WELL WEBSITE. BOTH OF
THOSE THE VERY SPECIFIC TERM
DRY WATER WILL NOT TROUT. THIS
IS A SELF REPORTING MECHANISM
THAT'S DESIGNED TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY COUNTY JOHNNA BY
THREE GROUPS RECOMMENDATION
INTENDED. FOCUS STEVEN YOU ARE
IN THE STATE WATER BOARD
ATTENTION AND DOLLARS IN AREAS
OF NEED. COUNTY THE PARTNER
WITH THE W. R. AND HAVE DONE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK TO GET
INFORMATION OUT ABOUT THIS
VOLUNTARY TOOL. I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT GET A CHANCE TO WORK. WE
RECOMMEND YOU REMOVE THIS
REGIONAL MANAGER LATEST ACCOUNT
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OFFERS
A LOT OF PENSIONS THAT IS
CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT ISSUES
WITH HER COUNTY TEEN. COUNTY
PROVIDING FOR STEPPING UP AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH CHILD
ACTIVITIES AND ALL OF OUR
COUNTY. WE WANT TO THANK YOU
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF OF FOR
ALL OF YOUR TIME. AND.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SADDAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP IN PER IF ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION HERE AND- IN THE
ROOM. BUT THE REMOTE VIEWING
STATE MISSION. THEY WERE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON SB
FIVE FIVE TWO MISTER MODERATOR.
YES THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN THE
JUNKYARDS OR OR OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME COULD BEGIN
BONDS AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ALL ACTION. CARBON CYCLE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
PZL P. FIFTY THEY ARE FABULOUS
IN STRONG SUPPORTER AT THE BY.
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TRAIN NUMBER THINKING A
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR
NUMBERS TO PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL
PATROL EXECUTIVE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR NEXT GEN POLICY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHT FIVE
FIVE TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WATER LINE NUMBER
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS A BOOST MARC THIS
WITHOUT COALITION BASED IN THAT
AND I AM SUPPORT OF. THAT BY
TWO. THANK YOU. SOON THE LINE
NUMBER FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
PARNELL SENIOR. I REMEMBER
SOMETIME I CALIFORNIA AT THE
CENTER OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY I
SHERMAN ALSO GONNA SING ANTHONY.
I AM AN ACTOR. MEMBERS OF OUR
COALITION AND NINE THE ONLY
EARNED TO DISAPPOINT ME FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXTRA GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
GOING ON TRACK WITH TRACKING
CRISIS THAT BEGAN IN THE WATER
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THREE
ONLINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT THE
ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA'S
BIGGEST. VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
NEXTCODE LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS NATALIE- I'M A WATER
QUALITY COORDINATOR WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER SB
BY BACK TO THE LAB GROWN MEAT
IS PAINFULLY CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER AT EIGHT THE SPEED
OF THIS BILL IF. IT WORK ON IT
THANK YOU. WE'RE JUST THAT- NAY
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSIST
DOCTORS JERRY BROWN'S LAKE AND
ARE AND REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
LINE. I HOPE YOU BURN IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN EXTRA
LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALEXANDRIA WHEN WE ASK
ME NUMBER THANK MEDIAN MEDINA
GOING INTO A LOT QUALITY ON THE
LAST ONE YOU WERE NOT ONLY THAT
THEY WOULD ALSO BE STARRING
MAJEDIE OUTWEIGH LAKKI BEAT
THAT WE LACK ANYTHING FOR THEM
THANK YOU FOR DOING IT THAT IS
NOT THE ONLY A STATE THING
UNION THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT OR
TEN ANIMALS THANK GOD THAT THEY
LACKED IDEA. ALSO SECOND AYE
JOAQUIN APPLE MONEY THAT IS
SPENDING LESS TO PLEASE THANK
YOU ROSTAND'S THREE THANK YOU I
THINK WHEN THANK. YOU YEAH.
THAT THIS TOWN NO AND- THANK
YOU MISTER RADHA RAIDER. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION A SECOND. MISTER
HERTZBERG WE LIKE TO CLOSE-
SORRY. MR LEVINE I TRY TO VICE
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO SENATOR
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL LIGHT
SIDE. MORE PLANNING ISN'T A BAD
THING AND YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE IN YEAR
TWO OF THIS DROUGHT BUT IT
FEELS LIKE YEAR THREE OF THE
NORMAL DROUGHT- IS. CAUSE FOR
CONCERN TO PUT IT MILDLY ON THE
WAY THAT WE'VE PLANNED FOR
WATERS GOT A CHANGE. JUST
ENTIRELY HAS TO CHANGE THE-
FUTURE DROPS WON'T GET ANY
EASIER. AND THE CLIMATE CRISIS
IS- IS REALLY JUST CHANGE THE
WAY WE GOT A LOOK AT OUR
RESOURCES. AND I YOU KNOW AS I
LISTEN TO YOUR OPEN- I BOTH
RELATED TO. YOUR GRIPES BECAUSE
WE'VE ALL BEEN IN YOUR SHOES AS
FAR AS TRYING TO TACKLE A
COMPLICATED SPACE AND POLICY.
THAT THAT ISN'T ALWAYS EASY AND
THE COMMITTEE PROCESS- IT AND
HOW WE YOU KNOW WORK THROUGH
SOME ISSUES AND HAVE AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARISE- AND ALSO YOU KNOW
HAVE. THE RHYTHM OF HOW THAT
WORKS OUT IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THE GAME YOU KNOW AS WE LEAVE
THE HOUSE OF ORIGIN AND THEN
PEOPLE START PAYING MORE
ATTENTION TO THE BILLS WE OFTEN
YOU KNOW IT'S PART OF THE
GRIPES IS OFTEN YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHAT THE OTHER HOUSE DOES BUT
IT'S MORE THAT STAKEHOLDER
START TAKING THE LEGISLATION
MORE SERIOUSLY. AND AND THEN
REALLY START TRYING TO SINK
THEIR TEETH INTO THE POLICY
WHAT IT MEANS HOW IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT THEM HOW WILL REALLY
WORK BECAUSE IN THE FIRST HALF-
SO TO SPEAK. NONE OF THAT WORK
GOT DONE OR OR DIDN'T ALL GET
DONE. SO WE START PAYING MORE
ATTENTION TO IT. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO. YOU KNOW ONE EXPRESS
THAT I RELATE TO THE FEELINGS
THAT YOU HAD ABOUT. HOW FOR
TAKING THIS MORE SERIOUSLY BUT
ALSO MAYBE THROWING UP SOME
ROAD BLOCKS TO SOME OF THE
LAUDABLE GOALS THAT YOU HAVE-
THAT THAT ARE IN PLACE IN IN
THE LEGISLATION BUT ALSO SOME
OF THE- MAYBE PERHAPS- FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE-
MISUNDERSTANDING OF THOSE GOALS
AND INTENTIONS AND WHAT THOSE
OUTCOMES WILL ULTIMATELY BE AND
LEAD TO FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
THIS LEGISLATION IS AFFECTING
AND SO I AM SENSITIVE TO BOTH
YOUR YOUR SIDE OF THAT STORY-
BECAUSE I'VE I'VE LIVED IT. BUT
ALSO SENSITIVE TO HOW WE CAN AS
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH- AND THAT
THIS COMMITTEE PROCESS YOU HAVE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE COMING UP
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT TO
USE THE WRONG TERMS ABOUT
CALLING SOME OF SOME OF THE
GOOD THINGS THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE BUT
THAT MAY APPEAR OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE TO THEM ABOUT WHAT
THEIR DUTIES OBLIGATIONS ARE
AND PERHAPS BEING MORE ONEROUS
THAN THEY WOULD LIKE THEM TO BE
WHICH MAY NOT BE WHAT YOUR
INTENTION IS. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE SPEED OF WHICH THIS IS
OCCURRING- TO THEM NOT FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE CAN MAYBE
CLARIFY THAT A LITTLE BIT DO
YOU SPEAK TO THAT A LITTLE BIT
PLEASE. CERTAINLY HAPPY TO. I
AM. MY POINT WASN'T CLEAR
CLEARLY THERE'S GREATER.
ATTENTION WHEN YOU GET TO THE
SECOND HOUSE THAT'S THE CASE.
AND THERE WAS OF AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROPOSED IN BECAUSE
IT WAS DOUBLE REFERRAL THE
TIMELINE SURE NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT. MY CONCERN WASN'T THAT.
DOES HAPPEN THAT'S THE NATURE
OF OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. Y
CONCERN WAS THE REPRESENTATION
pCOMMUNICATED I HAVE FOURTEEN
INSTANCES WHERE WE DID
COMMUNICATE AND THEY NEVER
RESPONDED OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. THAT'S MY
I CAN ALSO RELATE TO THAT. I
CAN RELATE TO THAT LIKE I CAN'T
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE THAT'S HOW
YOU DO BUSINESS AND SO I WANTED
TO PUT THAT ON THE RECORD AND
MAKE IT CLEAR. AS TO THE
SUBSTANCE MONTEREY COUNTY
TULARE COUNTY FRESNO COUNTY
ALREADY HAVE. A FORM HAS A BOX
THAT NEEDS TO BE CHECKED. AND
THE ARGUMENTS THAT ARE BEING
MADE. ARE JUST A DISINGENUOUS
BECAUSE- THE CHECKING OF THE
BOXES SELF EXECUTING ITSELF
SELECTING SELF CERTIFYING. SO
IT'S A REPRESENTATION BY THE
INDIVIDUALS THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL WORK. SO WHAT WE'LL
WORK IT OUT WITH WILL WORK WITH
THEM WILL ALWAYS WORK WITH THEM
I JUST WANTED TO STICK IT IN A
LITTLE BIT THE I. AND PUT
DIRECT PUT ON THE RECORD. DON'T
SAY THE MY OFFICE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND WE I'VE GOT A EMAIL
AFTER EMAIL THE RUN RESPONDED
TO. AND THAT'S ALL AND I
SUSPECTED THAT SEVEN OTHER
PEOPLE I'M JUST AN OLD MAN I'M
PUT UP WITH IT. THAT'S ALL YOU
DO SOUND A LITTLE BIT CRANKY
ABOUT I AM A LITTLE TRAINS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR CLASS I
DON'T I PROTECT MY PEOPLE WHO
WORK. HARD AND ARE RESPONSIBLE.
K. ALSO HAVE A CLOSE. THIS CHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE SIR YES YEAH
OKAY I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS WATER ISSUE SINCE I WROTE
MY DISSERTATION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND WORK WITH THE
CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE WORK
TO A LOT WITH LAURA FRIEDMAN
ASSEMBLY FRIEDMAN. WITH RESPECT
TO CONSERVATION AND IT'S BEEN
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. THIS ISSUE DOESN'T
AFFECT MY DISTRICT ONE INCH I
REPRESENT THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. 75% OF THE DROUGHT
IMPACTED PUBLIC UTILITY WATER
SYSTEMS WERE SMALL SERVING LESS
THAN A THOUSAND FOLKS. OUR JOB
IS TO BE A VOICE FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS ONE PIECE OF WHAT
WE SOUGHT TO DO WITH
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN WE WORK
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN. ON THIS
WHOLE DROUGHT ISSUE. AND NOW
WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
DROUGHT FROM 200-012-2000
SIXTEEN AND TOLD TO BE THE
DRIEST FOR YOUR PERIOD. IN THE
LAST FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS AND I WANT TO SAY THAT I
WASN'T HERE FOR IN FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHEN THAT HAPPENS. SEVENTY
THE SEVERITY IS UNPRECEDENTED
AND SO THIS IS PART OF THE
LARGER DYNAMIC I THINK. IN
TERMS OF US WORKING WILL WORK
TOGETHER WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
WILL WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
COUNTIES OF COURSE GOING
FORWARD. AS WE DEAL WITH THE
COMPRESSED SCHEDULE THAT OFTEN
IS THE CASE. BUT THIS IS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY AREA
THAT AFFECTS US AS A STATE.
GOVERNMENT IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT
IS HOW IT TREATS ITS MOST
IMPACTED PEOPLE. IN THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDERSERVED OR
HORRIBLE SITUATIONS IF DRY
WELLS. THAT HAD WE HAVE WATER
AND TULARE BEING BROUGHT IN BY
BOTTLES AND THE LIKE. MAKES MY
HEART LEAD AND I STAND HERE AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU TRANSACTION
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI MEGAN DOLLY NO MEGAN
DOLLY NO BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I KALRA KALRA HI LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MURATSUCHI MERE CITY I KNOW
WHEN. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS AYE AYES SMITH SMITH
NOVIA PADUCAH VIP DO AYE AYES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
HERTZBERG THAT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH A
QUESTION THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU. I'M SECRETARY RECALL
THE- ABSENT NUMBER ROLL CALL.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB SEVEN
OH EIGHT AND SB EIGHT TWO TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA I
EDUARDO GARCIA I. FRIEDMAN. SB
SIX TWO FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI FRIEDMAN. SB THREE
SIX NINE ABSENT MEMBERS EDUARDO
GARCIA HI EDUARDO GARCIA I
FRIEDMAN. EVERYTHING. WE WILL.
FOR MORE. LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK.
RIGHT. YEAH AT THE APOLLO HOTEL
ASSEMBLY.
FIVE FIVE AND I CAN
MAKE.
ONE WORKS WITH A METAL
SECTOR WE WILL OPEN UP- THE
ITEMS WILL START AT THE TOP
WITH SB THIRTY SIX NINE FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. SB THREE SIX
NINE ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. SB FIVE FIVE TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HI. SB SIX TWO FOUR
FRIEDMAN I CONSENT CALENDAR SB
SEVEN OH EIGHT CAN SB EIGHT TWO
TWO ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I ALL RIGHT. THANK U.
S. SECRETARY JAMES MATTIS- USER.